[Music]
hello and welcome
few would defend the wild disparities in
wealth in the world today and most
people support equality of opportunity
while society have tried to level the
playing field the rich are getting
richer while the children of poor
families struggle to improve their
situation
and it's not just the billionaires a
huge increase in property prices 20 fold
in the last 50 years have entrenched
wealth an opportunity across a slave of
middle-class households while making it
harder for the underprivileged to escape
poverty
if we want to reduce inequality do we
have to take a much more radical
approach to inheritance
why should we allow inheritance at all
is it just a means of embedding
privilege and those who already have
profound advantages or is it a
fundamental human right to be able to
pass on wealth to our children and would
its denial underline the very fabric of
society
and motivation to succeed well to
discuss this let's talk to our speakers
let's introduce our speakers david
is an award-winning journalist
broadcaster and has a reagan column in
the times he was previously president of
the national
[Music]
paul mason is a british commentator of
radio personality and was previously
economics editor for the uk's channel 4
news a former member of the radical
workers power group paul describes his
politics as now very complicated
and polly mckenzie is chief executive of
britain's leading cross party think tank
demos i bet that makes the second
leading one very cross when you say that
she previously worked as a business
journalist and director of policy to the
deputy prime minister nick clegg from
2010 to 2015 ladies and gentlemen your
panel
now in proper how the light gets in
style we're going to give each of our
speakers three minutes uninterrupted the
last time you'll be uninterrupted during
this session i suspect to put forward
their position on this question is
inheritance simply a means of embedding
privilege in those who have profound
advantages already and to start us off
david
the simple answer that is of course yes
and we all know it is
um
and we all know the things that we do
especially when we're parents to try and
do things for our children
which if other parents don't do them in
quite the same way or can't do them in
quite the same way have the effect of
embedding a degree of privilege in our
children and one of the things that's
really my my children my oldest is over
30 now my youngest is 24. they went to
three different types of schools and i
saw every kind of middle class gaming of
the school system that you can possibly
imagine together with every possible
reason given for doing it
right down to the very left-wing
american journalist
who took his son out of our daughter's
primary school on the basis that
labour's
policy for schools meant that they
couldn't provide a proper
education for a child as bright as his
was
um and as you can imagine the rest of
the parents took this
uh extremely extreme so i think i've
seen it in kind of every form uh that
that it exists
and yet
british people are incredibly edgy about
the question of drawing a line between
if you like what is a privilege that you
might not want people passing on
uh and a privilege or a set of
circumstances expectations that you
might want them
passing on and
the reason why i'm looking at my phone
there's i did i did take a look before i
came out that's something that happened
in the very early premiership of gordon
brown you may remember those of you who
are antiques that gordon brown took over
from tony blair and then thought well
maybe i'll have an election seems like a
good time to have an election
and then the whole issue of inheritance
tax came up
which was an extraordinary kind of thing
and george osborne
said this and this is how he's reporting
the guardian october 2007. mr osborne
said the inheritance tax fell
increasingly in quotes on the
aspirations of ordinary people with over
a third of homeowners now having it
hanging over them too loud cheers and
applause i think we can gather from
context this is the conservative party
conference he said the next conservative
government will raise the inheritance
tax threshold to 1 million pounds so
you'd have to have a 1 million pounds
worth of inheritance before you paid tax
on it taken together our measures on
stamp duty inheritance tax represent the
most important reform of capital taxes
for a generation we will take 10 million
people out of these taxes on aspiration
and so on so he cast the question as
being a matter of aspiration despite the
fact that the vast majority of people
would never get close to passing on that
amount of money or if they did
the tax on it would be neutral because
the amount would be only just over the
threshold and so on and yet that turned
or people felt that turned the pole
sufficiently for gordon brown at that
point to certainly say well maybe i
won't have an election after all which
turned into something like a
catastrophic mistake
my own view is that i would like to see
very hefty inheritance taxes um i don't
think uh just as i like to see taxes
significant taxes on all forms of
unearned wealth so that you aren't able
simply to take with you a advantage
simply as a consequence of your birth
or your parental preference your parents
preferences with you into the next stage
of life
but and i'll stop in a moment
that is only a very very tiny bit of
what is a very very much bigger picture
about what constitutes inheritance and
also the part that inheritance plays in
what we might call inequality
thanks david and we will be going on to
many of those points um shortly and of
course i think many of us here in the uk
will also be thinking about the current
debate about social care and inheritance
and how that comes to i'm sure that will
come up later in the the debate let's
turn though for the next take on that
question and reminder it's is
inheritance simply a means of embedding
privilege in those who have profound
advantages already paul mason can i turn
to you yes um and hello everybody it's
nice to be in a live tent isn't it um so
we've we live in a kind in a kind of
capitalism
that has turned out to be
very good at
raising inequality and widening
inequality both income inequality but
what we're talking about now is wealth
and to you know as i spent my time as an
economics editor
one should always explain income is like
sort of people's profits and wages and
and even rents
wealth is what they have in the bank and
the
and the shares they own and the houses
and luxury flats and lamborghinis they
own okay so it's stuff
um
income inequality is widened wealth
inequality however in this country is
off the scale um the bottom 50 percent
of us and i would probably think that
most people in this you know well turned
out though many of you luke and this is
north london you know you are probably
still in the bottom 50
many of you we together own nine percent
of
society's wealth
now what's the problem with that
income at least is contestable
there is always and has been in my
lifetime a struggle between working
people and bosses over who gets the
slice of the pie um you can you know you
can go on strike for higher wages in our
lifetime the profit share of the gdp has
risen and the wages share has shrunk but
not actually by a massive amount two or
three percentage points
wealth is different it's very difficult
to struggle over wealth and indeed over
the power that it that it and it gives
people
so
i'm not no big uh advocate of the john
rolls theory of social justice i see it
in a way as one of the ideological sort
of justifiers of the society we live in
but if you do use that yardstick raw
says you know under what circumstances
should we tolerate inequality and he
says well one of them is that the least
off gained the most from it i'm afraid i
cannot see
the current situation conforming to that
in any way
during the pandemic 650 billionaires in
the world
their wealth rose from 3 trillion to 4
trillion
through doing what nothing so what do we
do
actually if you look at inheritance tax
you could expand it at the last election
john mcdonnell uh labour's left you know
cha cha the chancellor only really
promised to reverse george osborne's cut
it would bring in about 700 million
we're talking we need billions to
transform society to redress inequality
to sort out climate change billions upon
billions upon billions and for that
reason what i favor is an in-life tax
rather than the inheritance tax an
in-life tax on the size of wealth and
thomas piketty for example who is one of
the key academics who studies the
sources of inequality believes that
everything above a billion you should
simply take 90 percent of it away from
people that's the kind of redistribution
i would like to see and against that iht
is a little bit of a drop in the ocean
thanks very much indeed uh paul and uh
we will no doubt i think return to many
of those issues in the wider discussion
but
last take on this first question is
inheritance simply means of embedding
privilege in those who have profound
advantages already polly
thank you um it was really brilliant to
see when paul mentioned taking 90 of the
assets away from billionaires quite a
lot of sort of churchill dog nodding
in the audience um
and
there's always a danger with an event
like this right that we all pointed a
bad thing and nod wisely and say yeah
that's bad but can't actually come up
with a way of resolving it or navigating
it it seems to me
it's very clear
that inheritance
along with the other thing that david
has mentioned education is one of the
key mechanisms
for the transfer of inequality between
generations
uh it's one of the absolutely
fundamental things we do perhaps the
third is genetics but it's quite hard to
think of a government policy that
changes that one
so we've we can imagine a government
that uses education policy
to to to try and level up uh as the
saying goes and then you've you've got
to think you've got to do something
about this transition of assets between
people
but the problem is
lots of people in lots of tents like
this have said that
and yet
what we've got in our politics is george
osborne talking about an inheritance tax
that
most people won't pay
and causing real you know lasting ripple
effect through our politics as a result
of it
so something must be wrong right because
if you ask people what should we tax
should we tax unearned wealth or should
we tax income people the vast majority
of people are really clear unearned
wealth we shouldn't be taxing income so
much you can get ri you can get people
on left and right enthusiastic about
that
the thing is that conflicts against a
value system people have around
inheritance
that says actually often inheritance
isn't
unearned wealth
it's unearned by me if my mom dies and
gives me a house right of course
but my mom worked her whole life to
build up that asset
there's a whole thing about housing
assets where actually a lot of the gain
has come from our stupid ponzi scheme
housing market but that's another event
not one that's on today but you know
i talk about it a lot but that
fundamental thing if it doesn't feel
like unearned wealth in the way that
connects into the sort of billionaires
thing about uh jeff bezos and how much
we'd like to take 90 of his wealth away
there's something going on in our value
system about the idea that you should
work hard and
we encourage people to make savings
right in their life
it's sort of active government policy to
encourage people to save for a rainy day
to put aside money to protect themselves
for their pension in retirement so that
they can have an income and not fall
back on the state we encourage people to
go into home ownership so they don't
have to rent or fall back on housing
benefit so we've we've got a whole value
system that says you should be working
hard to accumulate financial resilience
around yourself and around your family
if you look at people who experience a
financial shock that one of the top
three things that causes a financial
shock is an emergency loan to somebody
else in your family or friendship
network who's experienced a financial
shock because that's what we do we're
nice to each other so for me and we'll
get on to
talking about it i think we need to
think about what can we do that actually
connects into the value system that is
driving people instead of just pointing
at wealth inequality and saying that's a
bad thing we can't do anything about
and for me
that's
it starts with understanding that one of
the worst things that happens around the
transition of wealth going forward the
next 15 years is that it is going from
85 90 year olds to 60 65 year olds so
you're not
transferring assets to the young
generation who are going to start
business and do things
or even you know um
help their kids or tackle education all
you're doing is circulating money among
retired people and i love retired people
they can be great
lots of you look like you might be
retired but we
we should aim higher and for me that
starts by two things finding ways to get
people to give money to their
grandchildren and great chandra great
grandchildren and finding way to let
retired people spend a lot more money
having a lot more fun
thanks very much indeed that sounds like
manifesto we can all get behind i uh i
have to say i just had you said that
genetics is not something that
governments could do anything about
there were rumors that the government
last year briefly had a special adviser
who was very interested in questions of
eugenics but i think that was during a
different period in government from your
own and perhaps thankfully i think he
also wanted everyone to take this
intelligence pill right and where are
they available no okay we'll we'll get
to that that later on so thank you all
our pitchers for the first um uh set of
views on this question of equality and
how it relates to inheritance and i want
to separate the two things out just a
little bit as we carry on the discussion
let's talk about equality first because
we've heard a lot of language
particularly here in the uk in the last
year or so year and a half particularly
as people are coming out of the pandemic
about leveling up opportunity for all
making sure that we get better outcomes
but all the figures show that equality
certainly hasn't yet been achieved even
if that's supposed to be the end goal
and i wonder if the question is partly
based on a false assumption an
assumption perhaps which is a kind of
intellectual dishonesty that we want to
believe that we want to be equal but the
reality of what it means actually makes
us step away in other words are we
really in favor of full equality david
what would you say
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas